here's msnbc's Chris Hayes telling us
that the New York Times isn't a liberal
newspaper I'm going to bash my head
against the how long is this clip it's
like 12 seconds I'm gonna bash my head
against the desk for 12 seconds I'll be
back
now I disagree vehemently with Tucker
Carlson's assessment of bias in New York
Times it is not a liberal paper
his point though that the political
right lacks credible journalism is well
taken
ah oh
screwed up the timing on that one I
can't bash my head against the desk for
12 seconds I got kids downstairs I have
other responsibilities that clown these
people are insane like in he doesn't
think the New York Times if you mean
that they're socialists that they're
past liberal right they're past
Progressive if you mean that they're
socialist or communist you Muppet you
fake glasses glasses wearing Muppet then
I suppose I agree with you but otherwise
no no no no no no no
[Music]